Israeli police are recommending criminal
charges of corruption and bribery
against the Prime Minister of Israel
Benjamin Netanyahu the police say
there's enough evidence there's enough
evidence to indict Benjamin Netanyahu
not only for bribery but also for fraud
and for breach of trust in two totally
separate cases so first case Benjamin
Netanyahu allegedly asked the publisher
of a newspaper in Israel to portray him
positively when they talk about him and
in exchange Benjamin Netanyahu would try
to suppress a rival newspaper success
not good not good the other case is one
about Benjamin Netanyahu reportedly
receiving gifts valued at nearly 300
thousand US dollars from a variety of
different supporters including champagne
and cigars with the idea of getting a
Hollywood mogul named Arnon milchin a US
visa and police say that right after
Netanyahu received those gifts he also
started pushing for a law which would
allow Israelis who return to live in
Israel after living elsewhere for some
time to not pay taxes for ten years and
then lastly in another case Netanyahu is
suspected of fraud and breach of trust
relating to a Russian billionaire named
James Packer who apparently also made a
bunch of gifts Netanyahu and his wife
so obviously Benjamin Netanyahu is
denying the entire thing and it now is
up to the Attorney General to decide are
we going to file charges or not and that
could take months let's break this down
into the sort of broader analysis right
I've been rallying against Benjamin
Netanyahu for what a decade at this
point I think he's terrible for Israel I
think he is terrible for any reasonable
prospect for Palestinian peace he
doesn't want peace right Benjamin
Netanyahu benefits from a more escalated
status quo in Israel he's also aligned
in a coalition with the most vile
retrograde religious right-wing elements
of Israeli politics it's an alliance
that is completely deplorable and
depraved and there's just not going to
be any serious steps towards
Pease when Benjamin Netanyahu is Prime
Minister of Israel so I think he should
have been voted out already but he
hasn't been so listen if these crimes
are crimes he committed and that remains
to be seen then this is as good a way as
any of getting Benjamin Netanyahu out of
power if this removes him ultimately
then that's great and that's good even
if it's a different sequence than we
might have imagined now Netanyahu needs
to go one way or the other right there's
a question as to whether is the Attorney
General really going to charge a sitting
Prime Minister and the answer is well
there's precedent for it in Israel
previously there have been indictments
and charges filed against sitting prime
ministers at the same time there have
also been allegations made against
Benjamin Netanyahu in the past that
didn't lead to charges arguably because
prosecutors decided we just don't have
enough evidence here if true these are
really serious crimes because they
completely undermine the political
system and this is a guy Benjamin
Netanyahu who's been just a totally
toxic influence on Israeli politics and
on the peace process the almost
non-existent peace process for which yes
Benjamin Netanyahu is not the only one
to blame and you know I've talked about
that before but for a long time he has
been an impediment to peace so am I
personally offended by the allegations
against Benjamin Netanyahu no I've
always known that he's basically just a
right-wing extremist whose priorities
are just not in line with the people of
Israel do I believe he'll ultimately be
charged I really don't know but any path
to the successful removal of Benjamin
Netanyahu is something that we should
all be in favor of because this guy is
not going to be good for anybody
over the long term the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as $1 per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad